STEWART BRAND: Among economists, to what extent is there a consensus that the house is on
fire? MARIANA MAZZUCATO: In terms of how Greta [Thunberg] uses it? So climate? BRAND: You say basically it's in
trouble. MAZZUCATO: I mean the problem is that there's this—if the question is amongst
economists, there's a lot of introspection
about economic theory, where it's gone
wrong. And there's a movement really
about rethinking economics. And there's a bit of a danger there, because economists
love to show how mathematical and
scientific they are compared to
the sociologists and the anthropologists. And so unfortunately part of the
rethinking economics movement has bought into that and is trying to
make economics more user-friendly. You
know, the idea is there's too much math, we
need to make it much more about
real life. And the problem is that it's
not too much math, it's the wrong math.
It's math from Newtonian physics. And
it's all about equilibria, and
unique equilibria, and averages matter
and the representative agent. There were
all sorts of other mathematical tools
that could have been used, for example,
from biology. In fact, lots of the
agent-based modeling today—but that's
kind of ghettoized in economics, it's
not out there at the center—uses more
kind of metaphors and mathematics
from biology. But also, my thesis actually
was using replicator dynamics,
distance-from-mean dynamics. In
economics we assume averages.
In biology you couldn't explain
change if everyone looked the same right
distance from mean. You show your
growth by how different you are from me,
how different your fitness is. And yet
this focus on averages and
representative actors in economics is
fundamentally different from how
growth and change is looked at in
other sciences. And so I think what's
really important—and this is what I
guess I was trying to do also in the
book—is to debunk the
assumptions underlying the models, versus
to say, get rid of the math. But
in terms of the house being on fire with
climate change, unfortunately—and this is my point about just seeing it as
patching up different types of market
failures—it's not that we don't need the
carbon tax; of course we need carbon
taxes.
But not really seeing the green
transition and the Green Revolution
that's required as an active market
co-creation and market shaping process
across that whole system is a lost
opportunity. We should remember that big
revolutions in the previous waves of
technology, for example mass production,
would never have had the effect that
they did across the whole economy
without also really bold demand side
policies. So, suburbanization was
fundamental to the power of mass
production to really affect production
distribution consumption and
productivity. And what we need today is
the equivalent of these kind of demand-side policies like suburbanization, but
in a green direction. And we're not
really getting except in some isolated
cases.